health officials in Iran a warning of a
second wave of cases if people don't
follow the advice to stay at home
Iran's reported 158 people have died in
the last 24 hours
remember there are nearly 56,000
confirmed cases in Iran and despite the
warning of a resurgence industrial
facilities have been reopened
Noureddine adhira was given some rare
access to a hospital in Tehran here is a
look inside a pocketbook
Rhona virus has mobilized all medical
staff in the world here in Iran to all
medical staff have been mobilized we are
here at one of the most important
Iranian hospitals dedicated to treating
people with the virus the medical teams
and staff are available here 24/7 to
monitor and diagnose all the new cases
here is the place where new patients are
received and given oxygens via these
ventilators they're then placed under
strict supervision as doctors monitor
the conditions the patients are also
given necessary medicines according to
the international medical protocol in
order to help the patients recover Iran
is one of the worst affected countries
in the world but hopes are still high
the country can overcome the crisis as
more than 17,000 cases have recovered
Iran still needs a lot of ventilators
and medicines to fight off the virus and
that's why it's urging the international
community to put pressure on the US to
allow it to use cash from European banks
to import the necessary equipment Iran
also says there will be massive
consequences that will disrupt the
region if they are unable to contain the
spread a lot of medical researchers are
working here in this hospital to test
various medicines and their effects
fighting against kovat 19